talk about friendly exes bradley cooper
and arena shake sharing a total kodak
moment family is everything the model
gave fans a look at her modern family on
the gram posting vacation snaps
including this one her ex's abs on full
display good i'm great
check out the pair looking vacation
fresh arena in a floral bikini and black
mesh cover-up it's amazing while bradley
shows off his tan and some short black
trunks
happily smiling and again shirtless
right next to arena as she leans her
head on him arena simply captioned the
post with a heart emoji
the 36 year old also shared snaps of
herself in other bathing suits including
this one grinning next to some sharks
and check this out arena laying on the
beach a giant heart drawn around her
then the model hanging with cute water
pigs
now as far as we know bradley and arena
are not back together they split in
2019. the friendly x moment comes just a
month after et learned bradley had a new
lady in his life huma abedin a political
staffer known for her work with hillary
clinton our source says the two have
been quiet about their relationship and
avoided being seen in public so far
adding that they wanted to get to know
each other more before everyone chimed
in once they found out we imagine
bradley's daughter with arena is a
factor here too at least when it comes
to dating under the radar everything's
different when you're a dad bradley and
arina share custody of five-year-old
aaliyah
last year a source gave et a little
insight into their co-parenting
relationship
saying quote arena and bradley have been
in a really great groove in regards to
co-parenting for a while they both love
leah so much and want to be the best
parents possible
a lot of arena and bradley's
interactions and hangouts surround leah
and her schedule but they also get
together on their own they have a lot of
love and respect for each other yeah
it's very special
[Music]